hola en este vídeo quiero recordar
algunas de todas las cosas que hemos
visto con los logaritmos y vamos a
recordar la más básica para empezar que
decía que el logaritmo en base no sé en
base x logaritmo en base x de a es igual
a n vamos a suponer eso lograr en un
base x de a está igual a n esto quiere
decir la forma equivalente de ver esto
es que x elevado a la potencia n es
igual a a x cuando lo elevó a la
potencia en edad a éste de forma
equivalente de ver esto sin embargo
recuerda que aquí había cosas
importantes porque cuando yo me tomo el
logaritmo en base x de am mi resultado
es un exponente lo que estoy buscando
aquí es un exponente que exponente pues
el exponente n o dicho de otra manera a
qué potencia se tiene que elevar x para
que me dé resultado a mientras que aquí
ya no tengo x elevado en la n es igual
al que por cierto esto lo podemos
escribir la siguiente manera si
sustituyó a n por esto que tenemos aquí
que me va a quedar que
cuando lo elevó a la potencia logaritmo
envase x de a esto quien es igual pues
esto es igual a por que el logaritmo en
base x de a es n y sabemos que x elevado
a la n es igual a es pero no será un
poco confuso todo esto porque lo que
quiero ver en este vídeo es como se
demuestra en algunas propiedades de los
logaritmos o pensado de otra manera de
donde surgió toda esta idea de los
logaritmos lo que voy a hacer aquí es
fijarme en las propiedades los
logaritmos e intentar demostrar las pero
pero quiero demostrar las desde la
manera en cómo se descubrieron los
logaritmos y eso va a ser bastante
interesante y después le enviaré todo
esto así que déjame decir que x para
esto déjenme cambiar de color
voy a cambiar de color porque esto hace
las cosas más interesantes x elevado a
la potencia l x elevado a la potencia l
voy a decir que esto es igual a y bueno
si vemos esto en nuestro lenguaje de
logaritmos vamos a decir que el
logaritmo
x de a es igual a él estoy utilizando el
lenguaje de logaritmos ahora me voy a
tomar otra potencia de que pueda suponer
que x elevado a otra potencia vamos a
llamarle m l m y x elevado a la m es
igual a b
esto quiere decir en lenguaje de
logaritmos que el logaritmo en base x de
b esto es igual a m
recuerda solamente estoy utilizando la
definición del lugar y no estoy haciendo
nada fuera de lo común y ahora voy a
tomar otra potencia voy a tomar x
elevado a la n iv seguramente vamos a
decir oye sal a dónde va todo esto a
dónde quieres llegar con todo esto
ahorita vas a ver no pierdas la
paciencia y me queda que x elevado a la
n es igual y fíjate voy a definir a x
elevado a la n como a por b y bueno de
la misma manera si nosotros usamos el
lenguaje de logaritmos estoy diciendo
que el logaritmo en base x de aborden le
abordé esto es igual a n ahora bien
fíjate en lo que tenemos aquí tenemos
escrito x a la n es igual a por b pero
además sabemos que am yo sé cuánto vale
an a es igual a x a la l es lo que dice
aquí arriba y ven que yo también sé
cuánto vale bebé es igual a x a la n es
lo que dice aquí arriba también por lo
tanto puedo escribir a x a la n de la
siguiente manera
escribir como x a la l es decir a
recuerda que es x l l por lo tanto puedo
escribir esto como x elevado a la l x x
elevado a la m porque ven bsx elevado nm
por lo tanto lo estoy haciendo es
sustituyendo el valor de amd y el valor
de ven aquí en potencias que tienen que
ver con x x a la l x x a la m muy bien
pero una de las propiedades los
exponentes me dice que cuando yo tengo
en la misma base elevado a sus potencias
distintas lo que hacemos es que sumamos
las potencias o más o menos dice algo
así es decir conservamos la base y
sumamos las potencias aquí me quedaría
que esto es igual a x elevado a la l más
m me gusta esto de cambiar colores
porque lo hace mucho más entretenido
aunque es un poco más cansado pero bueno
es x elevado a la l más m muy bien y si
yo tengo que x elevado en la n es igual
a x elevado a la l más emt como ponerlo
hasta aquí estos de color verde y lo voy
a escribir todo con calma aquí abajo x
elevado online
acabo de llegar a que esto es igual a x
elevado a la l más m y bueno si esto es
cierto entonces las potencias tienen que
ser las mismas podemos cancelar la base
y nos va a quedar que n es igual a el
lema semen entonces déjame ponerlo aquí
n es igual a l más m así llegaron a
demostrar las propiedades de los
logaritmos n es igual a l más m m es de
color morado pero quienes n apoyos a que
el logaritmo en base x de apple b es
igual a n lo tenemos aquí arriba no no
no sí sí sí no perdamos la calma es esta
parte de aquí lo único que pasó es que
no escribí la en ese movido poner la
parte del lado derecho esto de aquí es
igual a en él porque nosotros sabemos
que así actúan los logaritmos x elevado
a la enésima labor de si el logaritmo en
base x de apple b es igual a n entonces
lo que voy a hacer es sustituir el valor
de n por valores de logaritmos me queda
que el logaritmo en base x de aborden
esto es igual a n esto de aquí entonces
déjenme escribirlo
en él lo voy a ver como el logaritmo en
base x de acorde ya lo estoy pasando
todo en lenguaje de logaritmos logaritmo
envase x de a por ven esto es igual a
ellen pero l también lo hemos escrito en
lenguaje de logaritmos esto es lo mismo
que el logaritmo envase x de am entonces
esto es igual al logaritmo en base x de
amd y después más m pero m es el
logaritmo en base x deben entonces voy a
sustituir a m por el lugar y tmo en base
x debe entonces me queda el lugar ismo
envase x de a más el logaritmo en base x
deben y esto es igual a logaritmo envase
x de a volver y perfecto esta es la
primera de nuestras propiedades de los
logaritmos y aquí está la demostración
ya llegamos a esta igualdad y por lo
tanto se cumple y fíjate que llegamos a
esta igualdad utilizando puros
exponentes recuerda que el logaritmo y
exponente está muy ligado el uno con el
otro perfecto aquí tenemos nuestra
primera demostración de nuestras
propiedades de los exponentes así que
voy a hacer otra en el siguiente vídeo y
con eso te dejo en este
y nos vemos pronto